so I was just complaining about
the day in your life videos that are all
that that are plaguing uh Tick Tock and
everyone does one no matter if their
life is interesting or not in almost
every case they're not
and uh I guess that's what led me Canada
to send me a bunch of other day in the
life Tick Tock videos which we'll now um
watch and
suffer through together
let's just go through these from the top
a day in my life being Clairvoyant and
seeing ghosts I work nights so I wake up
late at 11 A.M my partner brings me
coffee in bed and I catch up on social
media and reply to comments and emails
then I get ready for the day moving into
a house built in the 1920s I wasn't
surprised that there were lingering
Spirits here but honestly it's just like
having very elusive roommates oh the
door shut to themselves
at 1 pm I film and edit my content for
the day
then it's Physical Therapy stop it for a
second pause it for a second
oh the door you see the door shut in the
background
there's no other way it could happen
than a ghost how what other Force could
shut a door never mind the fact you
could see a person moving in the
background to shut the door you notice
something about ghosts is that they
always do things that like anyone
could do you know it's they they never
do they're ghosts they have supernatural
abilities they should be able to do
things on camera that could never be
duplicated
by anyone at least without the access to
Hollywood level special effects
ghosts could do that
instead and yet they never do
interesting
all the girls ever do is just like shut
a door
or drop a spoon
so God is let me try to I'm trying to
understand this God is allowing
Spirits the undead uh we're not Undead
they're dead
allowing The Souls of the Dead to remain
lingering around on Earth
so that they can shut doors and drop
spoons
what's the game plan exactly the funny
thing is that these people I can almost
guarantee it this uh LGBT member of The
Clairvoyant Community I'm gonna guess is
not
a would not describe yourself as a
religious person certainly not a
Christian she'd probably say I'm
spiritual but not religious
so what is your actual what's your
actual view of the supernatural Realm
what are do you believe that God exists
and if there's an afterlife many guys
she probably wouldn't even go that far
so how is it there's no God there's no
afterlife And yet when we die we still
have our like this Vapor that we shed
and that it lingers around how does that
work
ghosts only work if there is a God
there's an afterlife which there is of
course
but there's a God in afterlife then the
ghosts don't make any sense because what
are they doing hanging out here they'd
be going to their afterlife destination
okay continue and since we're already
out and about we go thrifting honestly I
just try not to buy anything haunted or
tacky as I look for pieces to build my
own collections when we get home I cook
dinner and we watch a show and tell the
ghost pacing in the den to chill out no
and then I unwind scrolling through Tick
Tock checking notifications replying to
comments and since I read everything it
takes a while finally at 2 am I turn off
all of the house lights and head to bed
okay
good unless that's what a clairvoyant
does uh and I guess this session makes a
living I don't know
I'm kind of I'm glad these people exist
because if you're dumb enough to be
scammed by somebody like this
to give them your money then you deserve
to be separated from your money so I in
a way I I am almost am thankful for them
I think they're
maybe providing a valuable service to
the world in that way okay the next one
is a day in the life of someone who
works at selfie World which is a thing
I've just learned existed and wish I
hadn't learned it let's watch
[Music]
all right okay stop just stop
what
I I still don't know what selfie world
is I guess I can understand from context
so
is selfie world at a mall
and people pay money
to go take a selfie
you're paying them money for the
privilege of taking a selfie on your own
phone
you have the entire world where you
could go anywhere and take any selfie
that you want you gotta pay that money
so you could take a selfie so you can
it's not even impressive backgrounds
here pay us money pay us uh 57.99 so you
could take a selfie in a room with a red
wall
you can't find a red wall like this
anywhere folks yet again people just who
deserve to get scammed and separated
from their money you've heard me talk
about how important it is to have a VPN
to protect your online privacy but
choosing a VPN you trust is equally as
important I like to do research on my
sponsors and I only recommend Brands to
my listeners that I believe in and that
I use to actually stop people from
monitoring your online activity that's
why you need to do what I do and use
expressvpn think about all the times
you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop a
hotel even a friend's house without
expressvpn every site you visit can be
logged by the Admin of that Network
that's still true even when you're in
incognito mode even in that case
expressvpn then is a solution it's an
app that encrypts all of your network
data and reroutes it through a network
of secure servers so that your private
online activity stays private expressvpn
works on all of your devices and it's
super easy to use the app has one button
you tap it you connect and your browsing
activity is secure it's that simple stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
walshyt use my Link at expressvpn.com
Walsh YTD three extra months free that's
expressvpn exp RSS vpn.com walshyt
um
this is a day in the life of a
wow you've really
put together a collection of the most
annoying people
on Earth okay there's a day in the life
of a van lifer this is a day in my life
as a van lifer with a cat the first
thing I'll do when I wake up is I'll put
on my slippers because it's cold next
I'll give Gigi his breakfast and then
I'll eat my breakfast
first I had a yummy dragon fruit and
then I headed inside of my girlfriend's
house so that I could make some soup
since it was so cold this morning
and of course a little bit of tea to
start my day
I always immediately open all the
curtains to get as much natural lighting
as possible
this will help me warm up the van a
little bit on these cold winter days
oh and since yesterday was laundry day
today I'll need to put all of the clean
laundry back in my bins and under my bed
after finishing up my laundry I noticed
that the floors were a little bit Dusty
so I decided to give them a sweep
after sweeping I decided to disinfect
them as well
next I'll check out my homework or watch
a fun video
then we'll take Gigi on a daily outing
so that we can all get a little bit of
exercise and be home in time for a yummy
dinner
okay there's so many it's like
we have ways of rebranding things and so
instead of people saying I live in a
trailer or double wide they say I have a
tiny home
no you live in a trailer and that's fine
by the way you can live in a trailer but
that's where you live in
this is not van life this is
homelessness
this is a day in life of me as a
homeless bone that's what it is
if you're even actually homeless like
this is cheating so she watched the van
is in someone's driveway and she can go
in there and make fancy soups and and do
whatever she that's not vanly the van
it's not van whatever van life is
supposed to be that's not it
you know what really
annoys me about this is that I don't
like how some of these things have been
appropriated and turned into like trendy
Tick-Tock things
if you actually want to authentically
live in a van down by the river and
you're let's say you're traveling across
the country you're driving around you're
being self-sufficient you're finding
ways to survive you're I I don't know
how you would what you do for food or
anything anything like that
I mean it's almost certain that this
girl is being subsidized by her parents
or somebody and so none of this counts
and none of it is real but if it's real
and you actually want to be
self-sufficient and you want to drop off
the grid and live on your own and do all
that I got tons of respect for that as
long as you're not being a burden or a
parasite and you're actually taking care
of yourself and you say this is the life
I want to live I I can respond it's not
the life I'd want to live I can respect
that but it's not even it's not real
though that's the problem here's one I
probably can't respect a day in the life
of a stay-at-home husband
sorry tough guys it's a day in the life
of a stay-at-home husband time to check
your misogyny at the door and buckle up
first thing I do is I make my wife some
coffee after making the bed then I do my
wife's laundry when juggling your
husbandly duties it's essential to
separate the lulus from the dryer next I
feed the dog because who else is going
to do it I start my dominance overall I
have left then I make my wife some
breakfast she likes her eggs air fried
with a rice cake and peanut butter then
I feed the plants before I feed myself
and I tidy up the house once the house
was clean my wife took me out on the
town followed and the patriarchy I'm
gonna throw up
I'm gonna throw up this guy exists to
annoy me hey that's my theory it's not
even a stay-at-home Dad okay this is not
a statement stay-at-home husband there's
no kids to take care of even
uh I gotta tell you something I don't
care how Progressive people pretend to
be I don't care how Progressive a woman
pretends to be
no woman
wants that or respects it it would
disgusts me now they might find some
benefits in it for a time because you're
staying at home doing your husbandly
duties at a certain point she's gonna
realize I don't actually want a
manservant I want uh I I want a husband
okay I want someone who's gonna
provide and be a man that's what I want
that's what every woman wants okay
you're a stay-at-home husband you don't
do anything
I gotta respect that
and marriage can't survive without
respect
all right this will be the last one
actually there's two more but I can only
stomach one more this is a day in the
life of a of a pilot which now this one
sounds interesting okay finally someone
with an interesting job
hi everyone here's another day for a
second now this is this is actually this
is a sabotage from my own team there's
nothing I can say here that will not get
me into trouble there's so much that I
want to say that I can't say
but I will say anyway which is that I I
would be terrified I would I'm not
saying it's the right response I'm
telling you emotion I'm being
emotionally vulnerable I would be
terrified if that was the pilot because
here's why I've been very clear about
this every pilot
on a commercial aircraft
should be a man with a mustache and the
man should be between the ages of 45 and
65. that's every pilot I don't care
about race or anything like that every
I'm very open outside of that like they
should all look something like the the
pilot that landed the plane in the
Hudson
that's so I'm discriminatory in that way
but um
okay go ahead and play it I woke up made
myself a coffee and then I started to
steam my work uniform and right about
here I actually got a call from crew
support to go fly that day it was a
local which meant that I'll be home the
same night which was nice because I
didn't really need a pack much just
brought a light suitcase just in case I
got stuck anywhere and then I started to
get ready I had three hours to report to
duty which gave me plenty of time I was
able to make myself a nice little lunch
and I also stopped by Trader Joe's to
grab myself a salad for the flight the
salad is really good by the way made it
to the airport took a shuttle to my gate
and once I got there I started to do all
of my pre-flight duties to make sure
that the aircraft was safe to fly and
then I started getting set up to go to
Omaha Nebraska I was excited because it
was my first time flying over there we
did that flight landed here we are now
in Omaha had about 45 minutes so it was
a quick turn before we needed to head
back to Los Angeles this was our route
for that night it was a little over two
and a half hours long each way it was a
nice flight though landed in my fun walk
around and that was it
all right
look I'm sure she's very
she hasn't crashed a plane yet I mean
I'm sure she's a very talented pilot
um
oh man okay
we'll just leave it there what's up
before we before I get myself into more
trouble
and uh that's it though so those are the
uh the days in the lives of all these
people I wonder I'm glad we could spend
some time with them and learn about
their experiences
feel like a better person for it